i've
spoken with david fravor on this podcast
i really like him as a person
he's a fun guy but also he's gotten the
chance to
um he's described his account of having
experience with the what
he and others now termed the tic tac ufo
uh what do you think of that particular
sighting which is captivated the
imagination many
in particular because there's been
videos released of it yes
of these ufos but i find the videos
to be way too blurry and grainy to be of
interest to me the
personally uh to me the most fascinating
thing is the
first person account from david and
others about that experience
but what are your thoughts those videos
have been out for a while
actually much i think in the mid 2000s
they were out
but what you have is you have kind of
like this corroboration
from a group and also the new york times
involvement
in 2017. my opinion about the tic tacs
is that
um first i believe the people
who have had the experiences i know some
of them like you know some of the radar
people and
things like that they saw them and
they're not i don't believe they're
making it up okay
um i do think that this is being this
is being used uh as a spin okay and i'm
just gonna say that
and the reason i think that is this is
because at the time it was released i
was still in touch with many people
who were among the ufo fight club and so
they had intimate knowledge of these
things
and the first thing they said was um we
have satellites that can
read the news on your phone when you're
reading it so
we've got better footage than this and
this is not
good footage at all therefore they
believe that it was authentic footage
that had been doctored up
now why i don't know why
um so i so i honestly don't know if it's
accurate or not i mean
i believe the people absolutely but was
this something out there
to fool these people perhaps i don't
know
um is it spun um the people who i know
who are part of the ufo fight club
believed it was real okay and said this
is badly done but real
okay i see but so there's some kind of
when you say spinning there's some
parties involved there oh yeah there's
another time to leverage it yes
for funds probably for funds for
financial interest yeah i think so
nevertheless it has inspired a
conversation
and just a lot of people
in the world that there's
something mysterious out there that uh
we're not fully informed about
and i was certainly grateful that the
new york times ran the story right
before my book came out
well see but there's the financial
interest that to me
as a person who uh doesn't give a damn
about money actually i don't like money
uh is um except for when it's used in
the context of a company to build
cool things but like personally i don't
know i find the financial interest
side off-putting um
especially when we're talking about the
exploration of some of the most like
money is a silly creation of human
beings
i agree and it's it's uh
used to provide uh temporary like
the unfortunate thing with money is that
it
helps you buy things that
too easily allow you to forget
the important things in life and also to
forget the difficult aspects of life
to do the difficult intellectual work of
being cognizant of your immortality of
like fully engaging in life
in a life of reason too of thinking
deeply about the world all those kinds
of things
if you get like a nice car or something
like that and just like
i don't know all the different things
you could do with money is
you it can make you forget that anyway
as a there's a long way to say that
yes yes it's very nice that it coincided
nicely with the book
but also it uh i think it
i mean like i said i think it inspired
quite a lot of people that
you know maybe there's a lot of things
out there that were
like it reminded a lot of people there's
things out there we don't know about
lex i can agree with you on that but can
i push back on two things
okay let's do it all right the first one
is that i was happy to receive money
from the book because of the new york
times article that's absolutely false
so i published my book with oxford which
is an academic press
and you don't get paid with an academic
press okay so money was not it for me
what it was was recognition that my
research was being validated
so you know because then people called
me and said well maybe it's more than
interesting
okay and they did okay the other thing
about money is just as you say
that now i agree with you there
i'm upset about money too i think there
should be universal
health care uh a universal income all
you know i don't think people should be
in poverty especially because
we are so wealthy as a species frankly
um okay that said think about this if
you
are if you don't have money you can't
have a life of the mind either
right 100 so i'm not espousing that like
money's the devil i just think that
there is money can be um
a drug or i would compare it to like
food or something like that where like
you really should have
enough to nourish yourself yes right
and uh too much could and too much can
be a huge problem
uh so that that's where i come from with
money and i'm just
aware i'm fortunate enough to have the
skills and the health
to be able to earn a living in whatever
way
uh like i wish of him being in the
united states and being able to speak
english so
the very least i could work with
mcdonald's and my standards are
i told you i made a mistake i told joe
rogan
that i've always had a few money and
people are like oh lex was always rich
no no
i was always broke what i mean by
uh i've always had fu moneys i think my
standard
what it takes to have a few is always
very little i'm just happy with with
very little
but yes it's true that uh money for many
people
and including for myself it's just a
different level for different people
is freedom yes freedom to think freedom
to do
to pursue your passions it just so
happens
i am very fortunate that many of my
passions
often come with a salary if i wished
right so like
everything like me i love programming so
even just like working
as a like basic level software engineer
would be a source of a lot of joy for me
and that happens in this modern
modern world to come with a salary so
yeah
it's it's definitely true i just mean
that it can be become a dangerous drug
so i'm glad
i'm glad you are in this pursuit that
you are in
for the love of knowledge and uh
but it's true yes uh people should
definitely buy your book
i won't be making money off of it oh
yeah this rocks yeah
absolutely maybe my next book yes
yeah your sense is there's something as
there's some groups of people that may
be
trying to leverage this for financial
gains
and you know probably good financial i
mean they may have good reasons for this
too
like okay let's take the study of ufos
okay
maybe many people in government that
decide
who dole out the money let's put it that
way they think ufos aren't real
so they're not going to give these
programs money so how do these programs
make money
um they're going to have to find a way
to do it so maybe
that's how they do it okay so it's
fascinating this is a way to raise
money for for doing the research
think
you